morning everyone thank you for coming
out and waking up for
this
um let's get
started uh so I'm Holly and today I'm
going to show you e type which is a
proof of concept for a new way of
building and extending programming
languages that I've been experimenting
with for the last year or
so so to set the scene uh when I started
doing webdev about 15 years ago uh PHP
was in voke and jQuery was everywhere
and there was no typescript and even
copy script is relatively new so working
in JavaScript itself was the norm and we
don't really do that today anymore why
is that well hopefully it's
uncontroversial to say that generally we
wish JavaScript were better um I don't
want to rag on it too much because
enough has been said about its flaws but
I do want to mention some key ones
because they motivate the shape of the
web dev landscape
today so the biggest one for a lot of us
is types as the IND history has moved
towards strongly statically typed
languages untyped JavaScript with its uh
unchecked runtime type errors has fallen
out of favor uh a lot of newer languages
also offer more powerful data structures
out of the box I personally find myself
wanting some types and then uh
JavaScript also famously has a lot of
these weird foot guns we have unusual
scoping behaviors with uh like far and
function and then we have these weird uh
type behaviors with coercion and these
different types of equality and these
have to stay in the language because it
has to remain backwards comp
so uh hopefully it's not presumptuous of
me to say that almost everyone who has
to work with JavaScript directly starts
to want many of these things to change
and as adoption of node meant more and
more code was written in JavaScript uh
we reached a point where the demand for
change started to justify a lot of
effort and so if you have a
dissatisfaction with JavaScript and an
ambition to change that uh what do you
build well for the last decade the
answer to that has been languages that
compile a JavaScript uh or transpiling
if you prefer
and this approach makes a lot of sense
you are completely free to come up with
your own syntax and then you can achieve
literally anything because you are using
Code generation to Target a t in
complete
language um and so these languages tend
to work like this you take code that's
in your new syntax and then you do some
sort of static analysis on it usually
type checking and then you take that
checked code and you transform it into
JavaScript which is the form where it
can actually be
run and so we got a lot of languages
that work this way uh typescript is the
biggest one but um there are the power
inflex ability of this approach means
that we have a lot of languages some of
which take very different directions
from
JavaScript but during that same decade
while we've been building all these
languages uh something else has also
been happening uh JavaScript itself has
also grown and matured um and so es6 was
the first big step uh we got Lettin
constant Arrow functions uh which help
us with uh these weird scoping behaviors
um we got classes so if you're coming
from an oop language you don't have to
know how prototypes work and then we got
things like generators and ASO we
that um just generally improve our quity
of life and we take these kind of
features for granted now but um they
were big steps in making JavaScript more
tolerable to work in and this started to
erode the advantage that these
transpiled languages have and so I
started to
ask do we really need all of these new
languages you know there is some
overhead to them uh languages introduce
a new syntact that you have to learn and
then you have to set up tooling like
bundlers and Source maps and then we're
putting all this effort into build build
these efficient JavaScript engines like
V8 and then they end up running
generated code anyway but also in
principle JavaScript is a scripting
language so what happened to being able
to just write JavaScript and then run it
and um the JavaScript like the
transpiling to JavaScript approach
brings so much to the table that
generally we accept this trade-off but I
do think it's worth asking what if
JavaScript is enough uh what can we
achieve within JavaScript
itself so if we go back to this list of
things that we want to change about
JavaScript we'll find that broadly we
can divide them into additive and
subtractive changes right like we want
to add types we want to remove these
weird
behaviors um how can we achieve these
changes without having to leave
JavaScript so for additive changes uh we
can use libraries and this is already
kind of the mindset of lisps where
libraries are essentially dsls that look
and feel a lot like they're just native
parts of the language and this is
tougher in more static languages with
weaker reflection but JavaScript is
dynamic enough that it's uh quite easy
to achieve this and so here's an example
of how we've how we're already doing
that uh this is Zod which is a popular
Val library for validating data types
and you'll see that it introduces its
own type syntax that mirrors javascripts
own so we've got these functions that
represent objects and string and number
uh and the biggest drawback with Zod is
that it only does checking at runtime so
if you want static type checking uh you
have to integrate it with typescript and
then we're back at square
one but actually actually it's uh worse
than that because even if you do
integrate it with typescript then you
end up with two syntaxes you have a
Syntax for describing your runtime
validators and then one for your static
types and I've heard this called Static
Dynamic bi formity it's the idea that uh
in many strongly typed languages you end
up with two distinct syntaxes and
infamously uh typescripts own type
system is itself teing
complete um and since the point of this
exercise is to see what we can achieve
within just JavaScript uh adding a
second syntax is
ideal but it does at least show us that
you know it's possible um so what about
constraining JavaScript so if we want to
constrain JavaScript uh we can use a
linter and maybe we don't usually think
of linters as constraining or reshaping
a language but uh we think of them as
tools for code correctness or quality
but they do so here's a simple example
uh this lint rule throws an error if the
programmer uses the double equal instead
of the triple equal which we rarely do
intentionally in JavaScript today um and
so if we consider all program that don't
pass this linter to not be valid ones
for example if we don't let them pass
our Ci or be merged into the trunk of
our repo then technically we are using
in our or a slightly different version
of JavaScript and so even though this
syntax is technically valid it's it's
valid syntax and it will run uh we don't
consider it to be a valid program and so
we can use this to effectively disable
language features but it goes further
than that because lint rules can apply
to libraries too so here's a lint rule
that catches when you're using a react
hook incorrectly and using the lter
we've basically constrained the set of
valid programs that use
react so here's an idea if we have a
library that's providing these language
level type features like type
annotations and then we have a linter
that's constraining the calls to that
library to only the correct ones we have
a type
Checker and so with this combination we
can sort of close the loop of static
Dynamic bity that Zod leaves open
because now we have the full ability to
add static typing to JavaScript from
JavaScript itself so we can add types
with a library and then we can constrain
them with a lter and so this is what the
process would look like um instead of
analyzing a custom syntax in a new
language and then transforming it to
JavaScript we take an extended syntax in
our existing language and then um the
code is runnable immediately there's no
transformation stage and so conceptually
we can build a new language while
concretely it lives entirely inside of
JavaScript so what would that look like
so get to get an idea of this let's look
at a stru declaration in a strongly
typed language like
go so Ino um this is a type declaration
which for us becomes a uh variable
declaration and then struct is a keyword
which for us becomes a function call and
then we use an object literal to
describe the shape of the struct and
then uh the types themselves would be
constants um and then since JavaScript
doesn't have an integer we use the
number
type and then the static analyzer would
recognize this call to struct as part of
a type declaration and it would
recognize point2d as a type and then use
that for type
checking and so this is the idea behind
e type it is a proof of concept language
extension I've never I've never been
really sure what to call it um built on
top of JavaScript that uses this
approach um oh and a quick uh note about
the name e type uh X type is a word that
means the opposite of a prototype and
it's also a pun on ecmascript and the
fact that it adds types to JavaScript so
we've checked all the boxes for these
terrible programmer anding
cliches um so now want to show you a
quick demo back type in
action can everyone see that okay cool
so here we have a program that's written
in E type this is a web server that has
one endpoint distance that calculates
the distance between two 2D points uh
the entire source code of the server is
on this left hand pane here
and uh we'll see that if I mess with one
of the
types oops I get a type
error right which goes away when I fix
it and then if I want to know where a
type comes from I can control click into
it and vs codee's own click to
definition will take me there because
it's all just JavaScript it already
understands it and then since this is
just JavaScript whoops I can uh I can
just run it directly without
building and then we can hit the web
server and get back a result and then if
I mess with the shape of the input data
um we get back a friendly error
message but not only that since it is
just JavaScript I can go into vs code's
own debugger drop a breakpoint into it
and then run the file directly no setup
this is just a Javascript file open in
vs code and then when we hit the
endpoint
we'll trigger the break point and then
we can introspect the values just like
it's a plain Javascript
file
so so going back to this type syntax
example I want to show how we actually
construct an instance of a type so
whoops sorry I forgot to
hit
save there we go
so if we go back to this type syntax
example um I want to show how we
actually construct an instance of a type
so in many statically typed languages a
bar struct is not allowed to exist uh
the struct has to be tagged with its
type like point2d here and so in E type
uh you do this using the uh you do this
using the from keyword um and then you
provide the object leral and so now we
have static type coverage for point and
anywhere that this point is used uh
we'll get type coverage on its fields
and uh what operations are valid on
them and just like in go if we use the
wrong shape for our object literal um we
get a type error a static type error
from our linter static analyzer and uh
once again this is technically valid
JavaScript it will run but um because it
doesn't pass our linter we don't
consider it
valid and by the way under the hood this
from function is implemented just as an
identity function it just passes the
value straight through and this is
because um the runtime is effectively
trusting that the static analyzer has
already taken care of type checking so
if a call to from exists in the code and
it's being run the assumption is that
value being passed through it has
already been checked so the the run time
doesn't have to do
anything and so here's a quick overview
of the data types and EC type uh an e
type the convention is for types and
only types to begin with uppercase
letters so all The Primitives are
represented with constants uh we have
null which is our unit type um and then
null is also shows up a lot because
undefined is forbidden inex type and
then we have Boolean number and string
which uh are are familiar and then we
also have unknown which is the uh top
type it works kind of like unknown in
typescript and so all values are valid
instances of unknown and then we also
have type which is the type that
represents all types themselves and uh
we'll come back to that
later and then uh for our compound types
uh they are declared using these keyword
functions so you uh we have struct which
you saw earlier we also have array
function and Tuple which is backed by an
array uh and then we have variance and
so I want to talk a little bit more
about variance because they're quite
important to e type so variants are an
implementation of some types based on
Rust enums and if you're not familiar
with some types uh here is a criminally
short explanation of how they work uh a
sum type is a data type where uh each
instance has to be one of a fixed set of
options called Tags so here an IP
address can be either a V4 or a V6 um
and then each tag can also contain a
data type within it so in this case
string which will contain the address
itself and then you can construct an
instance of the sum type with a value
that's wrapped in one of these tags so
here we see this is a string literal
wrapped around uh wrapped by
V4 and then you can pattern match
against that instance and the match
statement will allow you to unpack the
value that's inside of this sum type
instance and then it will also check to
make sure that you've covered all of the
tags so that your match is
exhaustive and so in X Type uh variants
use a similar syntax we have an object
where the keys of the tags and the
values are the
types and then you construct them using
of uh we use of rather than from because
it's not possible for a variant literal
to exist in plain JavaScript but this is
mainly semantic you don't have to worry
about that and then we match against it
using match and so uh this is still
similar the uh handlers are or the match
is described using an object where the
keys are the tags but unlike in Rust
each Handler is a fully typed function
so if you missed the type uh the
function syntax earlier uh this
describes a function that takes one
parameter a string and then returns a
null and we have to return null because
undefined is forbidden in type so you
might notice oh and the function body is
mostly the same and you might notice if
you're familiar with some types that
this is a little bit redundant uh the
string doesn't actually need to be
declared in the uh Handler of the uh
match because it should already be known
in the shape of the variant um but
actually later on we'll see cases where
this is not
redundant and then just like in Rust uh
you can provide a wild card Handler um
to the match statement and that will
catch all of the tags that you didn't
specify Handler for and then your match
will still be
exhaustive and variant are important to
e type because errors are handled uh
with variance and so we expect errors to
be returned in the form of a variant
that contains a sum wrapped around the
expected result and then a none uh
wrapped around null which represents
nothing and so this is like the option
type in rust or the maybe type in
hasal um and so here we have an example
of a number option
type and then we can write a function
that returns instances of this so this
is a function that might fail a division
function and so um if the divisor is
zero then we can't we can't safely
divide by zero so we return none to
represent failure and then if it's safe
we return the result but wrapped in
sum and then when we want to use the
result from this function uh we have to
also handle the case where the division
fails and the goal in E type is to
always try to handle errors in this way
um instead of throwing exceptions and in
fact throw is disabled by the
linter so we have the groundwork of a
language here but we've also taken a
rather unusual approach um with some
unique trade-offs um and so uh I think
it's worth asking what else can we get
out of it what does e type's unique
approach T us up
for so if we look again at this example
um we'll see that this 2D serves as a
name handle on the type that we've
declared but it is also a value that
exists at runtime and this means that an
X type types are values and we can take
this and run pretty far with it so right
off the bat we get type validation for
every type we declare just
automatically so in addition to from
every type uh every type provides this
conform method so like from conform
takes a value and asserts that it
matches a type so here we're trying to
conform this mystery value to a 2d point
and maybe this value came from an HTTP
request or a user input at the terminal
in any case we don't statically know
what shape this value is but unlike from
conform checks the type of this mystery
value at runtime and that's because
conform is not an empty function it is a
runtime type checking function that we
generated with the type when it was
declared and the trade-off of this is
that since we can't know the be sure of
the type statically instead of a plain
value the value is wrapped in an option
and so maybe point would be a variant
that looks like this and then if you
want to get at the validated value you
have to also handle the case where the
mystery value is not a valid valid 2D
point and this by the way is how the
friendly error message in the demo web
app is
achieved so uh if we look at this
segment of the code we'll see that we
still have static type coverage over the
point like we can safely know what
fields are valid and what their types
are and this is because conform kind of
does the inverse of what from does so
rather than the runtime trusting that
the static analyzer has taken care of
type checking uh now the static analyzer
is trusting that the runtime will take
care of type checking and so this means
that no matter where a value comes from
and what we know about it we always have
a way of getting static guarantees on a
type so if the type of value is known
statically we use from and if it's not
we use conform and then we also have to
handle the case where it's not valid and
this is one of the strengths of e types
approach we get both static and runtime
type checking from the same type
declaration because that type exists
both statically and at
runtime and then either way there's
always a region where we have
coverage and this means that X types
type system aims to be sound uh I say
aim because I've not proven anything yet
but um basically whether code is
statically checked or checked at runtime
unchecked type errors should be
impossible but conform actually goes a
step further than that um in addition to
validating unknown data types uh or
unknown data against known types we can
validate unknown data against unknown
types and to show you how this works I
want to talk about how generics are
implemented in E type so in E type since
types are values the idiom is to try to
resolve type matters in value space
rather than introducing new type
specific syntax so um because of this
inac type generics are just functions
that take a type and then return a type
right and then uh by default when we
have a function that returns a type uh
we can't make any static guarantees
about it because a function could have
literally any arbitrary Behavior inside
of it but um generics are very common
pattern so I would like someday for the
type Checker to be able to recognize
when the user has uh done something like
this
and then statically deduce the result of
a call to a function like this and then
use it for static analysis um so under
this hypothetical it would look like
this um the analyzer would recognize
that num pair here is a struct
containing two numbers um and then we'd
be able to make static guarantees
against it but unfortunately this
functionality doesn't yet exist in E
type um so instead nump pair is tagged
by the analyzer as deferred and this
means that the type Checker knows that
it's a type but it has no idea of the
specifics it doesn't know what field it
has or actually if it's a struct at
all and so if you tried to call from a
num a num pair and get Mak sta
guarantees against it uh you would get a
an analysis
error and in the meantime we can
actually still keep our static
guarantees uh using
conform and so here if uh the result of
conform is a sum wrapped around deferred
and when one of the options in a variant
is deferred uh the static analyzer will
recognize what you're doing and uh um
then when you try to pattern match
against it it will take the parameter of
the first Handler and use that to run a
uh to run a runtime type check against
the incoming value and this is why
including the type in the Handler is
important it's not actually always
redundant so like here uh this is the
only place where that type is known and
so using this pattern you can assert a
value of an unknown type to be of a
known one and then also gracefully fail
uh if this is not the case and so when
you do this you do have to always
provide a wild card Handler because even
if you do handle every case in the
variant it's possible for the incoming
value to match the tag but not the uh
parameter in the Handler right so in
this case uh if maybe num pair is indeed
sum but we describ the structure
incorrectly we would have to fall back
to the Wild Card
Handler and then once again we get
static type coverage in this region so
uh this is another case where the power
of E types approach really shines um the
runtime can pick up the slack where the
static Checker is unable to and uh we
never lose type coverage and this
enables us to we also don't ever have to
leave JavaScript to do work on types uh
we don't need a separate Syntax for this
which many other languages would
require and so there's one other feature
that I want to show that uh highlights e
types static uh runtime handoff ability
and that's conditional types so we've
seen how we can constrain a value to a
type um but what about constraining a
type to a value or a set of values so
for example the set of all positive
numbers or only strings that are valid
email addresses so in type we can do
that with conditional types um so we use
this keyword here cond and then the
first parameter to it is the parent type
so here all positive numbers are numbers
and so we base our conditional type off
of number and then anywhere that the
type Checker expects a number a positive
num will also be
valid and then the second parameter for
this conditional is the uh is the
JavaScript function uh expressing the
condition and returning a Boolean just
in plain JavaScript and this can be
literally any uh valid e type expression
and it can even close around other
values if you wanted to and many other
languages do Implement something like
this usually in the form of refinement
types um but they would expect that you
do this with a type specific syntax uh
but here we just get to use plain
JavaScript and actually these languages
that try to uh provide static guarantees
against this um type checking in these
languages can be incredibly difficult
and in fact it's actually possible for
type checking to become
undecidable but in E type we can just
cut the gordian knot and say just check
it at runtime with conform
and then once again we get static type
coverage over this value even though the
validation happened at runtime and then
later on we can even introduce static
checking in half measures so for example
maybe it's too difficult um to cover
this uh positive number function over
all possible uh variables that could be
passed into the condition but um we can
cover easily the cases where we pass in
a constant like here and so in cases
like that we can just warn the user like
hey in this specific set of conditions
that you're uh that you're trying to use
here we actually can provide you static
type coverage so conform is unnecessary
it will always succeed and you can
safely use from here and provide static
guarantees and then in all the other
cases where a type Checker uh still
isn't smart enough and doesn't have
coverage um we can just continue to tell
the user to use conform and it's the
same business as usual and so again
here's another case where this ability
to hand off responsibility between uh
the runtime and the analyzer really
shines and so languages that make strong
distinctions between uh type space and
value space that have this strong static
runtime bi formity uh would really
struggle to do this um because the realm
of validation would be trapped either in
the type space or the value space and
it's difficult for them to
interact and so there's one last feature
that I want to talk about there's the
question of how does e type interupt
with the rest of the JavaScript
ecosystem and so there are two main
features to e type that enable this um
the first one is that in E type all
values are just plain JavaScript values
so if you look at a a struct instance in
JavaScript if we were to print this out
we would see it's just a plain object
there's no additional tagging or
metadata associated with it and there's
a couple exceptions to this uh variants
don't exist in JavaScript so they have
to carry their functionality with them
and then functions also carry tags for
their uh parameter and return types
because those can't be deduced at
runtime but neither of these adversely
affect going from X Type code to plain
JavaScript so what about the other way
around for that we have this JS function
and this is kind of akin to rust's
unsafe
so the first parameter here is a
callback where you can write any
arbitrary JavaScript and the linter and
Checker are just turned off completely
and then the second parameter is this
type and the result of the call back is
just asserted blindly to be of that type
and so this is how we Implement that
HTTP server even though no HTTP server
library has been written in E type um so
we wrap around the functionality that we
want to expose and then um e type just
understands it to be of that type and
then that's how we are able to call it
so ideally you would only do this at the
boundaries of the program um kind of
like the functional core imperative
shell Paradigm um and then have as much
of your actual code be written in E type
um and of course you can still call the
E type type Constructors inside of this
JS body so you can create valid variants
and functions for
use so um we have made a lot of
trade-offs here and I think it's
important to acknowledge uh just what
we've given up for this uh degree of
flexibility um I think an obvious one is
performance um many types do indeed only
need to exist statically but in E type
they all exist in memory and actually
since we're not doing any code
generation we can't even optimize them
out um so I've have not benchmarked act
type but it can't possibly be good for
your performance to be spawning object
into memory that just don't need to be
there um another issue is verbosity
since all values have to go through from
and conform uh acyp code can get quite
verbose and the code the behavior around
pattern matching is also somewhat
verbose and then lastly um as a language
designer we're Lim lied in what syntax
we can add by having to stay within the
realm of valid JavaScript and so there's
a few things I wanted to add that I
couldn't like Universal function call
syntax and uh if Expressions that I just
wasn't able to um
add so as for what's next um there are a
lot of directions that this could go U
my focus is on adding on choosing a
relatively small number of relatively
powerful features to keep the surface of
the language small and I'm also hoping
to make the behavior more ergonomic
especially around pattern matching um
but outside of act type I hope that the
features that I've shown today Inspire
other language designers um even if the
combination of trade-offs that I've
chosen here is rather specific I think
there's still value in a language that
for example still offers code Generation
Um but still incorporates this static
Dynamic handoff that I've
shown so as for where it is now uh e
type is in its very early stages so all
of the code that I've shown today does
run but that is about the extent of it
and so I don't think I need to warn
anyone that's do this in production
because if you tried I think you would
hit bugs within minutes but if that
doesn't deter you you can npm install e
type today and try it out um and you can
also find a current version of it at my
gitlab repository here um and if you
want to talk to me about it more please
feel free to email me about it I would
love to talk your ear off about it or
grab me on the hallway um and then I am
looking for work so if you're
hiring and that's it thank
you
that